now we're ready to start creating canvas
tiles to catch some of our draw calls
will put this functionality in our pre
draw cache function we need to walk
through our Maps tiles and for each tile
create a new canvas tile container of
the correct width height and XY position
in the world after this we need to push
each canvas tile into a new array that
we've made to keep track of them inside
of our tiled map class so finally we
don't want to set the fully loaded flag
until true until after our canvas tiles
have been created and filled in so we've
modified our image loading callback to
rather than actually setting the flag it
calls pre-draw cache and said once all
of our canvas has been filled in we can
then safely set fully loaded equal to
true so that rendering can continue in
the future